[Musique]
on a beau être en guerre en Ukraine on a
déjà amorcé la reconstruction et c'est
important pour les Ukrainiens alors
aujourd'hui il y a eu des demandes il y
a eu des engagements sur la scène
internationale et puis on est en pleine
contrefensive qui ne savent pas donner
des résultats espérés peut-être par vous
et moi mais je pense que les
Ukrainiens sont très réalistes en cause
car elle professeur intitulé de la chair
en études du crânienne bonsoirl parlons
d'abord de la reconstruction en pleine
guerre déjà on fait les demandes on
octroie des sommes c'est important de
déjà commencer la reconstruction
évidemment on a le vertige quand on
entend des chiffres comme ça comme le
premier ministre ukrainien quand il nous
dit 411 milliards c'est difficile
d'imaginer pour vous donner un ordre de
grandeur toute l'aide militaire et
économique depuis 16 mois qui est
considérable 130 milliards donc on parle
de trois plus de trois fois ce qui a
déjà été donné puis qui va continuer de
donner
légèrement économiquement et qui
justement va payer la grande question
c'est qui va payer qui va assumer la
note un peu la facture on dit que ça
doit être la Russie mais comment alors
on discute ce que les avoir russes à
l'étranger comme les avoir de la Banque
centrale russe 300 milliards qui sont
gelés depuis février 2022 en Europe
parce que ça pourrait être saisi
confisqué ça c'est le grand débat parce
qu'on dit que ça pourrait perturber les
marchés donc on pense toujours à la à
l'économie mondiale quand on pense aux
sanctions contre les Russes c'est une
décision politique est-ce que ça
pourrait perturber les marchés quand
vous venez de le dire est-ce que ça
pourrait
provoquer une espèce de méfiance envers
justement la validité la fiabilité du
dollar ou de l'euro
mais là il y a la conférence à Londres
justement je la reconstruction vous avez
mentionné et puis ce qu'on entend là le
président de l'équivalent des HEC qui
aiment l'école
nous dit qu'on voit que la tendance s'en
va dans cette direction là on l'a vu au
Canada même il y a eu la saisie d'un
avion cargo là
la semaine passée
la Grande-Bretagne en fait des
déclarations aussi en disant que les
sanctions seront jamais levées tant que
la Russie va pas justement de payer il
reste d'y avoir des litiges devant les
tribunaux la question légale mais c'est
d'abord et en toute question politique
une reconstruction écologique je voyais
cette semaine qu'un petit hôpital d'un
petit village avait déjà un nouveau toit
puis c'est un toit l'énergie solaire
tout à fait mais quand on parle de
reconstruction à coup de centaines de
milliards de dollars c'est reconstruire
des villes entières qui ont été qui ont
été presque entièrement détruites on
pense à Marie-Paul bon évidemment il
faut ressaisir reconquérir Mario Paul
d'où la contre-offensive mais les villes
du dan basse là on parle l'énergie
l'industrie lourde des années 30-45 ans
tout ça c'est soviétique les mines tout
ça c'est du passé alors si on en vient
justement à une situation l'Ukraine
reprend le contrôle de ces
territoires-là doit reconstruire des
villes où on construit en partie des
villes qui ont été sévèrementées on le
voit dans le Sud versables qui
continuent d'être bombarder mais ça va
pas se faire de la même façon ça va se
faire à la façon du 21e siècle c'est
surtout qu'avec le barrage le carcoval
c'est c'est un grand défi aussi
parlons donc prélèvement de la
contre-offensive il y a beaucoup de gens
qui ont mordu ça va pas assez vite
monsieur zelencia déclaré justement à
Londres par visio ce n'est pas un film
d'Hollywood ça serait les choses ne se
passent pas comme ça dans la dans la
réalité l'attente d'un résultat rapide
n'est pas réaliste
c'est une ligne de front qui est sur
1000 km il y a c'est un des territoires
qui sont minés comme on n'a pas vu les
mines des mines qui font exploser les
soldats ou les tanks qu'on a pas vu ça
depuis la Deuxième Guerre mondiale donc
c'est considérable il y a les drones
maintenant l'écran n'a pas on parle des
drones en termes de surveillance
c'est presque la guerre des étoiles
c'est sans précédent de l'utilisation de
centaines de drôles de chaque côté du
forum pour essayer de voir où sont les
positions l'Ukraine n'a pas la
supériorité aérienne mais ils ont la
détermination puis ils ont des nouvelles
brigades qui ont été formées et puis va
libérer leur territoire ça va prendre du
temps ils sont convaincus que ça va
arriver mais si on continue l'analogie
de la Deuxième Guerre mondiale les
grandes batailles ça peut durer une
semaine ou deux semaines on parle de moi
et de moi et de moi sinon
il dit que au mois de mars ou avril 2022
puis lève le document il y avait une
entente
il y a pas de négociation possible dans
la situation actuelle
quand il y avait eu des négociations au
tout début de la gare en mars là
l'Ukraine était prête à dire ok on sera
pas dans le temps l'acrymère on la
laisse sur la glace etc mais l'Ukraine
voulait avoir des garanties de sécurité
du genre
de ce que le temps fait depuis 15 mois
la Russie jamais voulu accepter et 4
jours plus tard il y a eu bout de chat
alors c'est ça qui a tout changé c'est
finalement la guerre contre le peuple
ukrainien c'est ça qui a changé
merci beaucoup merci pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]